>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington, D.C.
>> We're going to go ahead and begin.
My name is Mike Apfeldorf, you are in
Library of Congress 101 for Teachers.
I would like to introduce our
presenter, Cheryl Lederle.
Cheryl Lederle has worked as an educational
resources specialist at the Library
of Congress since December of 2003.
She has advanced the Library's
educational mission
by providing professional development
both in person and via webinar.
She has also played a significant role in
shaping the Library's online repository
of classroom materials and resources
for teachers at loc.gov/teachers,
and continues to contribute to the
development of those materials.
She has 15 years of experience teaching English
at both the high school and
community college levels.
We're very lucky to have her here.
Cheryl, take it away.
>> Thanks, Mike.
It is my privilege and honor
to be here with you tonight,
giving you a tour of the
Library of Congress for teachers.
So this is me at an earlier
conference, just because you might
like to know who you're talking with.
So my -- some thoughts on what we'll do today.
We'll look at the what the Library has
for teachers, and we're going to look
at lesson plans, primary source sets, eBooks,
webinars and other professional development
opportunities, social media channels and more.
And along the way I would invite you to
use that chat box to share your top tips,
favorite resources and experiences
so that we are learning together.
I always enjoy hearing from teachers
and find it very rich and wonderful
to know what do you find useful,
where do you get hung up so
that we know what we might focus on next.
This is not going to be a search webinar.
We're only going to look at what we've built for
teachers in particular, but hold that thought,
I had some scoop as of about
3:30 this afternoon some scoop
on a search webinar, so just hold that idea.
What I'd like you to do first is take you
briefly to Capitol Hill to visit the Library
of Congress, as we do -- oh,
Emily, Taylor and Hailey,
I hope you resolve your computer problems.
Mike will interact with you about that.
While I'm talking a little bit about
where the Library is and what it does,
feel free to use the chat to let me know and
let everybody else on here know where you are,
what state you're in, what grade or grades
you teach and what subjects you teach.
So you'll see, if you look at this, to
orient you a little bit, near the top center
of the screen is a tall white figure,
that's the Washington Monument.
The orange circle that you see just about
dead center is around the Capitol building.
The big, big blue circle is around
the Library's Capitol Hill campus.
We have three buildings and the small
yellow circle is around the most famous
of the three buildings, the
Thomas Jefferson Building.
Thank you to those of you who are chiming in.
It looks like you come from many
different geographic places,
and teach a wide variety of subjects.
And I appreciate that.
A little more about the Library.
This is a different angle with
the Capitol front and center.
Behind the Capitol and a little bit
to the left, under the lowest box
of text there is the Supreme Court building.
And behind the Capitol and to the right
is, again, the Thomas Jefferson Building.
And I've always enjoyed the [inaudible] position
of these three institutions so close together.
So a little bit about the Library.
It holds more than 160 million items,
and to house of all those we have,
it's a changing number, but more
than 830 miles of bookshelves.
Just stop and think about
that for a minute, 830 miles.
From where I'm sitting in Washington D.C., 830
miles is, what, from here to Atlanta, maybe?
The Library receives 15,000 items daily.
Many of those are through copyright deposit,
and of those it adds about 12,000 items
to the collection every business day.
So it's a big and growing bigger institution.
Here's a peek inside, and what I'd like you
to do is take a good look
at this picture right now.
So if you're still typing, finish your
typing or pause your typing for a minute.
I'm going to pause for about 20 seconds
and ask you to take in as many details
about this picture on screen as you can.
But don't start typing them yet.
Now take just a minute and jot down
a few details that you remember,
and feel free to read what other people
notice and build on their answers.
So I'm going to pause my conversation for
just about 10 seconds while you answer this.
Thank you for kicking us off, Janelle,
noticing the arches and columns.
And Mary builds on that and notices very
specifically three statues in each arch.
Circular format, statues.
Maria notes that she finds the lights
on the table make the room cozy.
William says there are writing areas.
William, I might push on that a
little and say, what are the details
that build up a writing area for you?
Lots of details here.
A small eagle at the very top of the arches.
You guys are good observers.
Take a minute and scan this list and see, did
somebody notice something that you didn't?
So a little bit about this room.
This is the main reading room
of the Library of Congress,
perhaps the most famous space
within the Library of Congress.
If you are of a certain age you might have seen
this in the film All the President's Men .
If you're a little younger
you might have seen this
in National Treasure [inaudible]
a little more recently.
But this is an actual working reading room.
If you come to the Library of Congress here
in Washington D.C. and you're above the age
of 16 you can do your own work in this room.
So I just wanted to take you into the Library
for a minute, and I tied that to an activity
that we like to use to get people involved in
observing and comparing their observations.
You've done a great job of writing
down observations in about 20 seconds.
So now on to the main part of the tour.
We've visited the Library briefly.
Here's the Library's homepage.
And I will point out, I didn't
want to say this earlier
because I didn't necessarily
want you popping out,
but all of these slides are
hot linked to the page.
So if you want to explore something
now or through the recording later,
go ahead -- feel free to click on it.
It will take you to a new browser
window, and you just need to return
to this window to resume the webinar.
So loc.gov, the Library of Congress homepage,
under Collection Highlights
are tens of millions of items.
I don't know an exact number.
I'm fond of saying what's the most exciting
thing about searching the Library of Congress?
About 30 million items.
What's the most frustrating thing of
searching the Library of Congress online?
About 30 million items.
So we're going to zero in on the
Teachers page, loc.gov/teachers.
Again, this slide is hyperlinked.
My colleagues and I spend our professional
lives trying to make those millions
of primary source items more
accessible to you, to teachers.
And one of the easiest access points is to
subscribe to the Teaching with the Library
of Congress blog, right there
in the center of the homepage.
It's keyword searchable.
I did a search on informational text because
it seems like that's an important concept
and phrase in a lot of classrooms,
and this pulled up 22 results
on a variety of kinds of approaches.
And you can search it for other things
as well, whatever you're interested.
I'd encourage you to try a
few different approaches.
Back to the Teachers homepage.
I'm going to anchor out of this page.
Again, I would invite you in
the chat, if you have experience
with these materials, share them in the chat.
If you have questions, share those in the chat.
Mike will be harvesting them and I'll
return to them at the end of the session
and answer as many as I possibly can.
The first place I'd like to show you, I'm
just going to work through the left nav
of this page, is Using Primary Sources.
It's kind of a nuts and bolts of how to use
primary sources, why to use primary sources,
including engaging students, developing critical
thinking skills, and constructing knowledge.
Citing primary sources.
It might be small on your screen, so
I'm going to just point out to you
that we have published format examples
for Chicago and MLA, and we focused this
on the most common kinds
of primary source materials
that you would encounter
on the Library's website.
We have a lot of questions about copyright in
Primary Sources, and the Library is the home
of the U.S. Copyright Office, so we try to
answer at least some basic questions there.
Of course we get questions about
where to find Primary Sources.
And if you want to branch beyond the [inaudible]
things, here are some starting places.
And then finally -- and I'll return to this
and talk to it a little bit more later --
we have teachers guides and then
analysis tool for guiding analysis.
And, again, I'll return to that
in more detail in a few minutes.
Back to the anchor point, the Teachers homepage.
I'd like to explore some of the
classroom materials that we have.
This is perhaps my favorite place.
First you should note that
they're searchable by standards.
All of these classroom materials you
can search by common core or if you want
to use your own state content standards,
that, or we have aligned them to the standards
of a select number of organizations, if
you're looking for something that way.
The first place I'd like to pause and look
at more closely are the Primary Source sets.
Those are sets of primary sources
around particular curricular themes.
What I've pulled up is the Constitution because
last I checked this was the most popular,
at least measured by the
number of clicks into it.
And I'd like to point out that in
the red circle there are a couple
of stopping places we're going
to go in the next few slides.
Each Primary Source Set, in addition to Primary
Sources themselves, which you can see arrayed
at the bottom of the page, has -- there
will be a Teacher's Guide, the analysis tool
and guides are also linked here, and there's
a student discovery set attached to this one.
So first the Teacher's Guide provides historical
background, and also some teaching ideas.
What we heard from teachers when we asked them
about using the Library's published
lesson plans sounded very familiar to me.
What I heard was -- what we hard was that
they tended to pick out the primary sources,
pick out the ideas, and then reconfigure
those [inaudible] primary sources
into their own lessons.
And so these Primary Source Sets are
just that, it's the primary sources
and the ideas deconstructed, because
what we heard was teachers don't need us
to write their lesson plans.
Here's a closer look at the Teacher's
Guide and Analysis Tool page.
Up at the top we have two
versions of the analysis tool.
There's a printable PDF version that if you
want to use paper that is the route to go.
And if you're wanting to use
a digital tool there is a link
to the primary source analysis tool.
They're parallel to the analyzing --
to the Primary Source Teacher's Guides.
A general one for analyzing primary
sources of general sort and a number
of format specific ones, and each Teacher's
Guide has a question set aligned to that format
to help you as a teacher know the kinds of
things to ask your students to go deeper.
And here's an example of the analyzing
primary sources Teacher's Guide.
And I'm going to click back
to the analysis tool.
You'll notice it uses the same columns
of observe, reflect and question.
And I've put red circles on
a couple of places to note.
One is that this online analysis tool has
a dropdown, if you'd like to customize it
with questions by format, you
can do that using that dropdown.
And then what that gets you is the second,
slightly lower red circle is around a small --
Maria, it's on the website and
it's hot linked from this page,
so we'll -- several access points.
That question icon will give students
a set of prompts that they can use
to help them do a deeper
analysis of the primary source.
Again, the Teacher's Guide, one thing that I'd
like to point out that's on the Teacher's Guide
but not the primary source analysis tool is
at the very bottom there are
some follow-up activity ideas,
beginning, intermediate and advanced.
And I would say that those
levels are more the complexity
of implementing it than anything else.
I often use the beginning ones in
teachers workshops where I want
to deepen the user experience
without a huge heavy lift on my part.
So I recommend looking at those as well.
The last thing, and this was back
on the Primary Source Set page,
is 12 of the primary source sets
have an additional component
and that is a student discovery
set that's free on iBooks.
That's all of the primary sources
from the set loaded in just
for students with particular tool sets.
What's up on screen right now is an annotation
tool that allows students to draw on,
to mark up the primary source in
the -- on their -- in the eBook.
This might look familiar if you look closely.
This is a built-in primary source
analysis tool with questions.
You'll notice it has the same
sections of observe, reflect,
question and then in investigate.
And so -- and there's a sample
question there that a student could ask.
So we've made this interactive for
students in a couple of different ways,
trying to make it as flexible for your
use as we possibly, possibly could.
The next place I'd like to take you from
the classroom materials is a quick look
at the presentations and activities.
I'm not going to go into every click of every
page because that would be a much longer webinar
than we have time for, but I do want to point
out that we do have presentations
and activities.
For example, the American Memory
timeline, access to primary sources
through a timeline of American history.
I'm going back to the Teachers page now.
Again, this is my anchor point for you.
And I'm just going down this left
navigation and I'd like to take a peek
at Professional Development now for a moment.
You are participating today in professional
development but we have other options.
So taking a tour of this
page, take online modules.
We have six self-directed online
modules addressing the kinds
of questions that we hear most often.
What does the Library of Congress have for me?
What does an inquiry approach
look like with primary sources?
And that's an interesting module
because it has actual footage
of fourth graders analyzing primary
sources in deep and really meaningful ways.
Copyright and then two samples of
analyzing primary sources using two
of the more popular visual formats,
photographs and prints, and also maps.
And then we have a module
on finding primary sources.
Now is the moment I'm going to tell you that
if you're really interested in learning how
to search the Library's website
more effectively and efficiently,
just this afternoon we scheduled
a webinar December 10th
for PM Eastern time, that's the current plan.
As I say, we just settled
on this this afternoon,
but watch the Twitter feed @teachinglc or the
Teaching with the Library of Congress blog
for details on this, if that's a topic
of interest to you to go more personally
and more deeper than these online modules do.
Back to the Professional Development homepage,
if you're trying to figure out where I am.
We also have PDF's available of the kinds of
workshops we deliver when we work with teachers,
and that's all there for a click,
and to get away [inaudible].
It has everything you would need to develop
-- excuse me -- to deliver a workshop.
The next thing is webinars.
We are in the middle of one right
now, but we host these at intervals.
And one of the things to know
is that we also record them.
So if you go to this page you can see
that so far this year we did a
Constitution Day Primary Sources webinar
and that recording is available.
And there's a link to this event, the Online
Conference, and all of these recordings will be
up beginning next week, available for
you to watch and share with friends.
Back to the Professional Development page.
Every summer we host Summer Teacher Institutes.
Those are weeklong programs that teachers
apply and get accepted to come to.
We have -- do not charge for these,
so this is a great opportunity.
There are your fees for travel and lodging,
but with little advanced notice a lot
of teachers have been able to get grants
through local organizations for that.
So if you want to do a really
deep dive and come "live with us"
for a week, that's a terrific opportunity.
And we'll be putting up that application
I would say within the next month or so.
Mike, if you have details on
that, add that to the chat.
I say that because, not to put Mike
on the spot, but because he's one
of the main organizers of that event.
Back to the Teachers homepage.
I'd like to anchor you again and point out we
have a number of local partners -- thanks, Mike.
Look for that application coming up in December.
And, again, watching the
Twitter feed and the Teaching
with the Library blog are the best places
to have the early information about that.
We have part -- a whole consortium of partners,
the Teaching with Primary Sources partners,
throughout the United States, providing
professional development more locally.
And as part of that program there's
also a journal published online,
and that's a rich place if you
want to explore some theory
and get also some practical applications of
that theory you might explore the TPS journal.
It always has a current issue and right now that
is Teaching with the Fine and Performing Arts.
But there's also an archive and
we'll look at that in just a moment.
So here's what's in a typical TPS journal issue.
There's a feature article, in this case, Primary
Sources from the Fine and Performing Arts.
There's a section on research and current
thinking, if you want to explore that more.
There's a Teacher's Spotlight, an interview with
a teacher who's been working with this theme.
And then there will be learning activities
at both the elementary level
and the secondary level.
Because, again, when we talked
to teachers we learned --
we heard that teachers are very adept,
you are very adept at adapting things up
or down a little bit, so you don't need
us to write a first grade lesson plan,
but you can see an elementary level one and take
it to the level appropriate for your students.
Here's the archive.
So you can see there are
a lot of topics covered.
Literacy Integrations, elementary learners.
I saw a couple of questions
flash by on elementary
and Mike will be giving me
those questions a little later,
when we pause for question and answer time.
Historical thinking, so lots of topics
here if you want to learn the theory
and also see some more activities.
I would be remiss if I didn't point out one of
the perhaps best kept secrets of the Library
of Congress, and this might be
the answer for a number of you
who have had some family specific content
questions that I may or may not be able
to answer in the context of this presentation,
but the Library offers an
Ask a Librarian service.
And you can see the little pink
box at the top of the page.
That will take you to this page and you
can see this is staffed by a wide array
of experts from all over the Library.
So think about if you have a teaching specific
question, probably directed to Resources
for Teachers, my colleague, Dana,
who's also staffing our Twitter feed
this afternoon, will field those.
And she is dedicated to getting you an answer.
There she is in the chat, hi, Dana.
Dana is dedicated to giving you an
answer within five business days
and often much, much sooner than that.
But if you have a content specific question
about, say, newspapers and periodicals,
for example, or you're a language teacher,
you can see we have a number
of international collections.
The Library collects in more than 100 languages.
I should know that number but
I don't off the top of my head.
I want to say 140.
Colleagues, if you have the number at the
top of your head, feel free to correct me.
So use this service -- 500 languages?
Good golly.
Anyway, I distract myself reading the numbers.
Use this Ask a Librarian service
if you're not finding something
that you believe we probably have.
Here's a list of high level resources.
Library's homepage, loc.gov.
And, again, these are all hot links, as are all
of the pages in this, from during the session
and also during the recording, you
can go directly to any of those.
The page for teachers, where I've spent most
of my time this evening, is loc.gov/teachers.
And we do maintain a blog,
blogs.loc.gov/teachers,
and that's a terrific place to explore
some of these particular questions as well
for teaching elementary students.
We have a science teacher in
residence who's been blogging,
so we have more science than in years past.
So if you haven't visited us lately
and that's of interest, check us out.
As I say, this is a terrific place
to explore some ideas and learn.
The things that I really enjoy about the
blog is it's a place to hear from teachers,
and so we appreciate your feedback.
Mike, I'm going to leave this
slide up and ask you to --
what questions have you fielded for me?
>> Well, a few questions.
Let's start with -- and these are [inaudible]
questions, so you can answer or Dana, also,
if you're still on the chat,
you can chime in, too.
But Maria asked, "Do you have materials
I could use in my Spanish class?
And specifically for elementary."
>> Maria, if you're looking for
materials that are in Spanish, we --
most of what we have is probably going to
be a high reading level because you layer
in the fact that it's historical.
But I'm making a guess on that because
I've never taught elementary Spanish.
I will say that what we hear from teachers
is that the visual materials cross language
and so if you're having your students analyze
a photograph, for example, or read a map,
they can do that in any language and
practice their language skills describing.
The other resource that I would point
you to, although it is outside the scope
of what I said I was going to do, is I've just
put in the link for the World Digital Library.
We had a whole session on the World
Digital Library earlier this evening
and you might check that out.
They have materials in many world
languages, and the information
about those materials can be translated
into seven different languages,
all the languages of the UN plus Portuguese.
And Dana chimes in, thank
you, Dana, I knew that one.
But [inaudible] America or Historical
Newspaper database also has some Spanish
language newspapers.
And Dana has pasted in the
link to the advanced search tab
where you can specify materials by language.
So there are a lot of things.
The other thing I would point out is --
Dana maybe you can find the link
for this while I'm chatting --
we do have a Primary Source Set that we've
built out of the World Digital Library
and that might have some ideas for you, also.
I'm going to pause, Maria, if you
want to clarify your question,
I see you're typing, that's terrific.
Mike -- thank you, Dana,
that was very efficient.
Mike, if you have another question while
Maria is typing hers, I'll go ahead --
awesome, I'm glad that you find visuals helpful.
I see a number of people
typing, so I'm going to pause.
And, Mike, what's the next --
>> Sorry, I believe I was muted.
Emily asks, "What materials would you suggest
for an English teacher doing
a unit on the American Dream?"
>> Emily, that's a huge question, and I
think there are probably a lot of things,
depending on exactly how you're students
or you defining the American Dream.
There is, as Dana has pointed out,
a lesson plan on the American Dream,
and that would certainly be a starting point.
I would suggest adding to that a
good search in Chronicling America
to see what experiences people had.
Just give me a yes or a Y if you can hear me.
Janelle, I see is asking about sound.
Yes? Okay, perfect.
Thank you.
Just wanted to make sure.
As I was saying, I would explore Chronicling
America as well, because I know for certain sure
that Chronicling America went live online after
the American Dream lesson plan was published,
but those are some terrific starting places.
Mike, what's the next question?
>> Just to -- and also just to
reinforce what Cheryl said earlier,
while she's doing a really good
job and Dana is doing really a job
of answering these [inaudible] Ask a Librarian
feature is really something to utilize
for these questions, as well, as
they're going to take the time
to give you very thoughtful answers as well.
So the next question is from Christopher.
He's asking about the use of the
resources are permitted -- are uses --
it really has to do with copyright.
Can they use these as a teacher?
>> If you're -- I'm not sure from
the site, yes, almost all of them.
Please all of the materials
from the Teachers Page,
all of the teacher specific materials are
entirely for your use, use them as you need to.
Share them lively.
We do like it if you give us
credit, but, yes, use them.
That's why we create them.
And since they're created by government
workers for hire as part of our job,
they're not covered by copyright, so take those.
Most of the primary sources are also
outside the bounds of copyright.
And when we build teacher materials we're
pretty particular to check whenever possible
that they're not covered by copyright so
that you don't have to worry about that.
I'll always point out, though, I am nothing like
a copyright expert and that's my disclaimer.
But for the most part, if you're using
them in the course of your normal teaching,
you're probably covered by Fair Use.
You'd want to do a much closer investigation if
you're doing anything published or putting it
on a t-shirt or something
commercial that you might sell.
But, yes, Christopher, I hope
I've answered your question.
And if you have more details or
something I haven't gotten to,
please feel free to add those into the chat.
Great questions.
Thank you.
Michael, what's next?
>> Here's another question that's come in.
This one is one that often comes up.
Does the Library have a copy of
every manuscript ever produced?
So I've heard of a manuscript, can I
automatically get it at the Library?
>> Boy it would be great if we did, but we
don't, so that's kind of a quick and easy one.
No, I don't think anybody in the world has
a copy of every manuscript ever produced.
I'm just going to jump line, Mike,
I see that Christina has asked,
"Are there any new library materials
or programs for teachers on the horizon
that you can get a sneak peek of?"
You know, yesterday our director of
Education Outreach did a whole program
on just what's new and what's coming up.
So if you weren't able to attend that,
Christina, look for that recording next week.
And we're always up to something
and that's all I'm going to say
about that, but watch the recording.
>> Cheryl, do you have time
for one more question?
>> I'm doing great on time, so bring it.
>> Cheryl, I have another question.
I believe you might be muted.
The question is, "What's the best," it's
kind of from a new teacher's perspective,
"What's the best way for me to
get started with Primary Sources?"
You may have to unmute [inaudible].
>> Sure. I'm just muting when you're
talking, otherwise people get feedback.
But thanks for reminding me of that.
You know, as a new teacher I think
the best way for you to get started
with Primary Sources is probably to
explore those primary source sets.
And Mike or Dana, if one of you
would want to plug that link
into the chat box that might be helpful.
But skim the list of Primary Source Sets, find a
theme that you're teaching, and then pull up one
or a few related primary sources.
Think about your teaching purposes.
Look at the Teacher's Guide, see what
ideas there are, and then dive right on in.
You know, give it a try.
Ask the -- you know, give the
students some space to work with it.
One of the things that we hear from teachers
is pretty consistently how surprised they are
that their students are able to think way
above what they would necessary expect.
So, you know, dive right in.
If you have somebody in your district or
building who's experienced with Primary Sources,
you might ask that person for tips, too.
And especially if it's somebody who --
if you can find somebody who's teaching
your same subject, that person might have
in mind some ideas on how you could get started
that might already tie into your curriculum.
And I see some of you thanking me.
That's wonderful.
You're very welcome.
I'm glad that you were able to join us.
I will point out, before you leave, we would
be grateful if you would give us a little bit
of feedback via the three questions
about this session on the Survey Monkey,
and the link is right there on the slide.
Mike, I'm going to mute myself, I believe
you have at least one more question for me.
And we have a few minutes, so if there are more
questions [inaudible] put them in the chat.
>> Yeah, I'm -- I will --
my typing will catch up.
But essentially the question is, what are --
from your experience working with teachers,
what are some of the creative ways that
teachers are using these primary sources
with their students?
>> I love that question.
There are so many creative ideas
we have heard from teachers.
The thing that has struck
me most recently is just how
across the curriculum Primary Sources can
be a good fit for teaching content ranging
from anatomy to astronomy to languages
other than English, to English itself.
And I -- as you may or may or not noticed in
the bio, English Language Arts is my background
and I'm just constantly delighted
at the possibilities with that.
One of the things that I personally
have been engaged with is breaking
in those historic American
newspaper pages to add some depth
and context to the Primary Sources.
Especially if you lay the foundation
with visuals and then ask your --
invite your students to continue their
research with additional primary sources.
And the newspapers were wonderful for that.
They're also wonderful for propelling
additional kinds of questions,
because of course when you're looking
at a newspaper page you're not reading
about just the one thing you started with,
and that's maybe a little bit of a danger
of using the newspapers because
it's easy to get sidetracked,
but I call that building historical context.
And Bonnie is pointing out, thank you,
that she loves using photographs
as a way to engage students.
And absolutely, it's visual,
it levels the playing field,
students can access the photograph
according to their own experience.
They can observe using that
skill that you used earlier
in the program, thank you for playing along.
And you can then deepen it.
One of the things that I particularly,
again, English Language Arts teacher,
love about photographs is talking with students
about how a photograph has a point of view.
Perhaps more subtle than a written piece,
but there's absolutely a photograph.
And thank you for all of the ideas
you're sharing with each other.
Thank you for the questions.
Mike, I'm going to mute myself and back to you.
I haven't been tracking the questions, so I
don't know if you have anything more for me.
Dana has been busy putting in blog posts
from teachers documenting their uses.
Mike, any other questions
or is it time to wrap it up?
>> I don't have any more questions.
We do have another minute, if
somebody else has a final question,
please enter it in the chat window or if you
are Dana have anything final for the good
of the cause now would be a great time.
Okay, with that said -- oops.
Well, Christopher comes in with a question.
Here you go, Christopher asks, "May school
groups come to the Library of Congress?"
That's a great question.
>> And the answer is absolutely.
Many, many school groups come every year.
Christopher, if you are planning something,
I would say -- and want something formal,
our Visitor's Service Offices
do great tours for students.
They fill up fast, so if you know [inaudible]
planning to come, you should absolutely --
I'm sorry, I'm getting distracted by the chat.
This is I averted my eyes, so I'm going to
avert my eyes from the chat again for a moment.
You should absolutely contact the
Visitor's Services as soon as you know.
Oh, Iris, that is my favorite
question of the night.
I'm hoping you're sitting down.
I just -- the fee for these
online resources is nothing.
We are your tax money at work.
There are no added fees.
Please use them, please share them, please use
Ask a Librarian to find more that you can use.
Dana has posted the link -- the direct link,
if you want to explore a visit to the Library
of Congress, Christopher, or anybody else.
It's a beautiful space, wonderful exhibitions.
>> Well, thank you, Cheryl.
I agree, it's been a great session and thank
you so much for leading us through that,
and also for everybody in the
chat for your great ideas.
And thank you, Dana, as well for
all your work in the chat, as well.
I want to reinforce what Cheryl said, we'd love
to have your feedback following this session,
so please click the survey link there
and provide any feedback you have for us.
It's greatly appreciated and it
helps us improve the program.
Other little items that you
might want to know going away.
In five business days you will be send
instructions to access a certificate.
The certificate will show that you've completed
one instructional hour for this webinar.
And depending upon your school district you may
be able to get continuing ed units for that.
I believe we've also mentioned this session
has been recorded, so next week check
out loc.gov/teachers, if you want
to watch the recording again,
and even perhaps more importantly please
share that link with your colleagues
so you can introduce them
to these resources as well.
Well, we thank you again for attending this
session, Library of Congress 101 for Teachers.
Good luck with your use going
forward, and please do not hesitate
to contact us with any questions.
Thank you.
Good night.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.